city of las vegas will soon get a new  gathering spot downtown it's called  civic plaza and it'll feature new  offices taking up a whole city block  mayor carolyn goodman says it will help  bring city employees back to one  location as they've been scattered a bit  since the beginning of the pandemic but  she also envisions much more for that  location  i can see community gatherings and  parties that we would want to have  events lectures  art  presentations and of course government  announcements and government activities  as more developments go up downtown she  hopes the area will be a draw for the  remainder of southern nevada no word yet  just on when construction will begin